oh yeah mark Walton you're here to talk
about Assassin's Creed unity yeah 7 out
of 10 review went up this morning it
take you up this morning it's ok yeah
yeah it's good but not great
what are your criticisms did it seem to
be the story stuff fellow flash and yeah
the buggy as well yeah I mean so the
biggest thing for me is the story
basically you know it's set in like
revolutionary Paris which is awesome
like the backdrop you know it's a great
setting right you think they'd be able
to do some amazing stuff with it right
and there's some cool looking stuff like
you've got these huge crowds and things
like that the story is just like I'm
this dude and song is killed you okay
like his dad gets killed at the guiness
beginning of the game of a spoilers the
very beginning of the game very
beginning it's the first thing that
happens and you're like okay I'm going
to be an assassin now aren't I because
someone's my my dad's diapers yeah every
Assassin's Creed game stars me run don't
I don't care anymore
it's like Chekhov's gun if you show a
video game dad that dad has to be i
before the end right yeah right so I
hope they have a sport of it that does
happen in like the first two minutes
yeah
yeah it's just the stories just like
this this or love story of I don't
really don't really be all like the
characters are in love at all yes
none of that Paris backdrop is used RIT
well at all and what you're saying
bugs yeah so it's got a bunch of
technically I saw like the PC version
apparently it's been a bunch of folks
having problems with it you reviewed it
on Xbox one we have still had like what
like three options though yeah well it
still had issues I mean the pc version i
haven't played personally but i have
seen some of the footage and yeah that
tender has been like the buggiest one
out of all of them the expo swarm from
i've seen has been the smoothest no
really there are some issues is like pop
in issues and I feel very severe Poppins
with large crowds especially is there's
more people to NPCs when you're swimming
through them you're just kind of hat
will come out of nowhere yeah exactly
it's really weird and there's like it's
like bits where like NPCs recently start
walking in midair okay
you will do it as well like you go over
a jump those on point was like trying to
jump from like a post to another post
and instead of jumping just went
[Music]
captured it but it was just yeah great
so it sounds maybe a little bit like
Assassin's Creed one hell was a little
bit rough around the edges and then by
the next one they kind of what it's new
tech right yeah you know this is a new
engine that they've been working on for
like four years or whatever yeah seven
million people have been involved other
than three twelve thousand studios yes
so that's about right yeah I heard that
I'm selling every time long yeah it's
kind of nuts and it's it's not ready but
I needed them probably like another
thing really I reckon there's one of
those things right it's like this is the
Christmas game yeah yeah it has to come
out super soft Christmas game right they
don't get this out or with farcry right
which does look a lot better this then
you know they kind of screwed and if I
guess with watchdogs they already ran
that sort of yeah dauntless wouldn't
Denari learn from that as well I mean it
wasn't ready there's there's issues with
it everyone's noticing I'm talking about
but it was it was delayed by six months
like they did it all time they did in on
this one well I don't think they can
afford it - yeah it's this is the cash
cow right Assassin's Creed 900p lock
baby yeah
[Music]